have you ever wondered what would it be
like to taste food for a living well
that's what these people do
they're called sensory evaluators you
might call them taste testers but
there's so much more than that
[Music]
my name is Gale van Seville I am the
founder owner and president of sensory
spectrum and I have been in the sensory
business for over 50 years
you do the math sensory evaluators are
trained for over 100 hours more on that
later they evaluate the texture flavor
or fragrance of a product from toilet
paper to chocolate to cheese they test
it all why do sensory evaluators do what
they do very often our job is to look at
prototypes with some ingredients
substituted so that we can tell the
product developers yes you are safe
making this in the place of your current
product and still having the same
sensory properties there's a whole host
of reasons why a product might change
like swapping out an ingredient for
something cheaper or healthier
take for instance kraft mac and cheese
remember when they change to all-natural
ingredients no preservatives or
artificial dyes but the flavor stayed
exactly the same boom thank your sensory
evaluators the role of sensory
evaluation is to stand next to the
product developer and say if you have a
charge to make a new product to make an
improved product to make an ingredient
substitution I am here to tell you
whether or not you succeeded were you
able to maintain the appearance the
flavor and the texture of that product
that is my job I stand there and say you
know what this is this is very very
close or it's spot-on I think you should
move forward with it
so how would Gail describe cheese cheese
there's either sheep cow or goat dairy
so there's milk and then there's milk
fat and then there are the fermented
notes that are in the milk so let's take
cheddar cheese which is a cow milk
cheese
that has milky notes milk fat notes
nutty notes skunky notes sometimes fecal
or as we like to describe it the
technical term poop and it actually
belongs there when you have farmhouse
cheddar cheeses from England or Scotland
or Wales or some places in Australia you
will have a fecal note that belongs
there and then you also will have
potentially some fruity notes as well
and salty sweet sour and bitter and then
you have all the textures which is the
hardness and the melt and the chewiness
or cohesiveness and how fast it
disappears in your mouth and whether or
not it leaves a fatty film to evaluate a
new or altered product they gather a
panel each panelist is handed a sample
in this case pasta sauce they'll taste
the sauce and evaluate its flavor
texture and smell then they rate each
attribute on a scale bitter there's an
entire book of terms to describe
different foods Gael wrote it brassy
minerally flinty if you will
sweet and sour milky notes nutty notes
skunky notes how do these panelists
identify how salty or sweet something is
during training they're exposed to
different levels of flavor a to salt is
very mildly salty while a 20 salt is
closer to ocean water and so on panelist
learn these until their second nature
the whole idea of being a great
panelists is to never think about what
you're doing just do it like a hockey
goalie just catch the puck you're no
longer mentally processing when I taste
I literally feel like the sample goes
into my mouth and then the sample tells
me about itself how has this training
affected sensory evaluators in their
daily lives I'm not a normal consumer I
am not normal I am very picky if I'm in
a restaurant where a lot of people are
wearing fragrance I will not enjoy it so
when
has jaded me or poisoned me or corrupted
me to being really obsessively picky
about what I'm eating where I'm eating
and when I'm eating for better or worse
actually tasting what you eat may be a
good thing I will try anything
I have eaten bugs I have eaten worms
I've eaten any of those things it's like
and some of them by the way are
presented to me as a challenge